bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 9
novembre
depuis le 5 novembre la vie des
clayes-sous-bois célèbre le centenaire
de la grande guerre plusieurs rendez
vous sont proposés nous découvrirons
deux expositions et cette semaine sera
marquée aussi par le premier
anniversaire des attentats de paris l'an
dernier 130 personnes perdaient la vie
des saint quentinois ont décidé de leur
rendre hommage
le week end dernier bois d'arcy organisé
la deuxième édition de son festival sur
la bande annonce nous ferons un retour
sur cette soirée le 11 novembre la
france comme aimant rat comme chaque
année l'armistice de la grande guerre et
en cette année de centenaire la commune
des clayes-sous-bois propose une
programmation riche autour du conflit de
la musique des projections de films des
spectacles mais aussi des expositions et
parmi ces expositions
certaines retrace le destin des hommes
qui ont combattu qu'il soit clé siens ou
issus des colonies françaises regardez
il s'appelait jean marius louis ou
encore pierre marie et ont participé à
la grande guerre
19 que les siens ont perdu la vie dans
le conflit l'association ville
proviennent ces jeux vie retrace leur
histoire de poilus dans une exposition
aux clayes-sous-bois une histoire
oubliée pour certains nous avons cherché
là la transcription des actes de décès
de tous ces poilus nous avons parcouru
les
et registres paroissiaux et à ce titre
on a découvert quatre soldats qui sont
donc derrière moi ils sont mis à
l'honneur puisqu'ils ont été oubliés sur
le monument aux morts qui a été fait
juste après la guerre en 1921 alors que
sur le livre d'or
établie en 1930 il figure bien ils
étaient tous quasiment agriculteurs et
ils l ont ils ont vécu la vie de tous
les poilus de français
et d'ailleurs elle des clés siens des
français ont combattu mais pas seulement
parmi les troupes des soldats issus des
colonies de l'hexagone leur nombre réel
est discutée par les historiens
l'exposition ensemble présente la place
qu'ils occupaient dans les rangs
français on parle souvent des poilus on
a parlé aussi un petit peu des
tirailleurs sénégalais qu'on appelle
carrière sénégalais mais qui regroupe en
fait tous les combattants de l'afrique
noire
voilà mais il faut associer bien sûr les
wav
du maghreb tous les combattants
asiatiques qui ont été aussi beaucoup
utilisé pour construire nos routes nos
chemins de fer voilà qui ont été aussi
utilisé sur le front beaucoup de choses
ont été dites comme le fait que ces
armées coloniales ses combattants en
particulier des tirailleurs avec utilisé
comme de la chair à canon mais ce qui
n'est pas le cas maintenant les
historiens ont vraiment des documents
qui prouvent que ses combattants étaient
associés aux poilus
et de manière égale pour la plupart plus
d'un million de militaires sont morts
pour la france lors de la première
guerre mondiale
cette année marque le centenaire de la
bataille de verdun
les expositions sont à découvrir
jusqu'au 20 novembre
il ya tout juste un an 130 personnes
perdaient la vie à paris à saint-denis
des milliers d'autres étaient blessés
depuis les hommages et les initiatives
en faveur des victimes et de leurs
familles se multiplient et à 50 ans
divine ça se passera ce week-end au
scarabée la salle vers iroise accueille
deux jours de concerts regarder une
salle du scarabée deux jours de concerts
et onze artistes pour une même cause
là ils font humanité est organisée par
plusieurs associations yvelines one
tout simplement pour rendre hommage aux
victimes du terrorisme et surtout pour
alors pour faire voir à ceux qui nous
ont attaqués il ya un an et au 14
juillet que nous sommes toujours là
toujours debout et comme dirait on est
toujours vivant des artistes français
comme d'alban l'îlot one is innocent ou
encore les fatals picards répondu à
l'appel des associations et a des goûts
touchés par les différents attentats
terroristes
pourquoi
ra de nolwenn à scorpion il y aura
toujours un conte
avec un drapeau de retour
ils ont perdu leur onzième lumière et un
geste sont donc qui était au bataclan
madame jardin donc ils ont bien sûr
voulu rendre hommage à cette personne ne
leur équipe
extrait important pour eux et nous avons
d'avoir une descente aussi qui était qui
a été très engagé suite aux attentats du
charlie hebdo qui a fait un clip qui a
fait une chanson
tous les bénéfices de ces différents
concerts seront versés à l'association
victimes du terrorisme
deux jours de musique pour se souvenir
un autre événement en lien avec cette
commémoration des attentats du 13
novembre l'a7 à montigny le bretonneux
25 artistes photographes peintres
graphistes se rassemble certains sont
professionnels d'autres amateurs leurs
oeuvres seront mises à la vendée tous
les bénéfices iront à l'association 13
ans 15
écoutez stéphanie lavaud elle est à
l'origine de cette exposition
comme beaucoup de personnes je me suis
sentie impuissante et en colère et je
voulais vraiment aider les victimes de
ces attaques mais voilà je ne savais pas
quoi faire je ne savais pas comment m'y
prendre
et du coup est née cette idée
d'organiser une exposition devant d'art
caritatif donc pour aider ces victimes
je vous en parlais la semaine dernière
la deuxième édition du festival de la
bande annonce se tenait à bois d'arcy
samedi soir durant deux heures le public
à échanger que l'animateur télé et
journaliste vincent perrot sur une
cinquantaine de bande annonce retour sur
cette soirée que les images de nicolas
landry séance de cinéma un peu
particulière pour ses 400 spectateurs
cinéphiles ou curieux ils venaient
découvrir des bandes-annonces bois
d'arcy organisé la deuxième édition de
son festival b à ba c'est comme ça en
fin de compte qu'on voit au cinéma une
bande annonce apporte beaucoup pour nous
donner une idée du film je suis revenue
cette année parce que nous avons
participé à la première édition l'année
dernière on a beaucoup aimé on a trouvé
que c'était vraiment sympa instructif
c'est très plaisant de voir
de revoir des annonces de films anciens
et surtout des bandes-annonces qu'on n'a
jamais vu une cinquantaine de bandes
annonces étaient proposés d'époque ou
d'aujourd'hui western course automobile
comédie ou encore film romantique une
sélection réalisée par le parrain ce qui
est amusant c'est que depuis la première
édition de l'an passé je ne vois plus
les bandes-annonces tout à fait de la
même façon c'est à dire simplement à
titre personnel je les vois avec
toujours une petite arrière pensée bois
d'arcy je les regarde et puis je me dis
tiens celle là il serait pas mal pour
bois d'arcy c'est à dire que là ça fait
un an que j'y pense des anecdotes
historiques ont été partagés tout au
long de la soirée par vincent perrot
pour prouver cette année encore que la
bande annonce est un art à part entière
cette semaine nos professionnels du
cinéma qui nous donne son coup de coeur
c'est marilyn pour des yeux d'elsa de
saint-cyr-l'ecole écouter bonjour ce
mois ci au cinéma les yeux d'elsa deux
événements deux coups de coeur avec une
ciné rencontres autour du film une
vérité qui dérange une ciné rencontres
organisées avec alternatiba et une ciné
rencontre également le 25 novembre avec
le film réparer les vivants le très beau
film de katell qui les verrait alors
pour le premier événement une vérité qui
dérange avec albert alternatiba nous
allons recevoir gilles rammstein shinra
stein qui est un climatologue et auteur
donc c'est l'occasion de faire le point
sur ce film et sur les avancées
après donc ce documentaire d'al gore qui
était voilà une sorte de plaidoyer
contre le réchauffement climatique
donc l'occasion de faire le point avec
jim rash times le 19 novembre c'est
notre survie ils se croient qui est en
jeu ensuite le deuxième événement c'est
le 25 novembre avec réparer les vivants
nous aurons l'occasion de recevoir
pascal tirés qui est coordinatrice
hospitalière des prélèvements d'organes
et tissus pour avoir une réflexion sur
ce domaine un peu particulier
scientifique assez inexplorés un très
beau film romanesque danse et qui montre
voilà le
le transfert d'organes d'une manière
assez étonnante vivante et très
touchante et comme chaque semaine on
termine notre magazine avec l'agenda
culturel on prend d'abord la direction
de plaisir et du théâtre espace coluche
ce jeudi 10 novembre vous pourrez
découvrir l'histoire de bryan et hommes
ils veulent vivre leur amour au sein de
l'église mais se heurte au refus du père
raymond on regarde un extrait être
pianiste c'est vraiment une vocation
être gay s'est fait un simple fait
simple pour qui j'aime les et je suis
amoureux de maria et je crois à
l'obéissance mon père je trouve qu'il ya
quelque chose d'un raid héroïque à obéir
pas vous ouais voilà ça mont royal pour
qui les avaient héroïne de vous déviez
qu'est ce que je fais
du 14 au 18 novembre c'est la sixième
semaine des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés ou empêcher le merdy 15
novembre une rencontre est d'ailleurs
proposée avec trois d'entre eux c'est à
la salle de la tour de voisins le
bretonneux et en théâtre à saint cyr
l'école le théâtre gérard philipe
repropose amok une plongée dans la folie
furieuse que peut créer une histoire
d'amour passionnelle la pièce est
interprétée par alexis moncorgé qui est
molière 2016 de la révolte de la
révélation masculine et c'est à
découvrir le mardi 15 novembre regardez
cet extrait vous savez ce que c'est que
la moque
c'est une ivresse gm allait une sorte de
rage humaine une crise de monomanie
meurtrière insensé mais assez sous
l'empiré de cette folie que je me
précipiter moins d'une heure après
l'entrée de cette femme de ma vie je me
jette dans le vide comme un hameau l'an
dernier le thème était l'environnement
cette année c'est le sport le festival
saint quentin revient quatre jours pour
découvrir des documentaires autour de la
thématique du sport
des animations sont aussi proposés le
festival débute avec un documentaire se
tenir une heure le jeudi 17 novembre
regardez un extrait
moi je suis quelqu'un j'ai parcouru lui
de par mon statut de parce que j'ai fait
par le passé j'ai pas loin
c'est un loupé le sait la venue de
l'allemagne ma maman et mon baba
scénario
c'est une culture est maintenant
terminée je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis les programmes continus sur tv
fil 78 et de mon côté je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine